[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
yours I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast for me
and my brother John we will answer your
questions give you dubious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey John how are
you doing you know I never prepare an
answer to that question even though you
ask it every single week I should
probably spend like 30 to 40 seconds
before we start recording the podcast
considering how I'm doing I'm fine I
don't know I've just got just got back
from tell me a story yeah tell me a
story I just got back from London so I'm
a little bit jet-lagged but we had a
wonderful CERN I had a wonderful trip to
London we saw lots of art we were there
for the art assignment with got to film
an art assignment with the gorilla girls
one of the great art collectives
of the 20th and 21st centuries which was
incredibly exciting that was super cool
just getting to hang out with them is
amazing and super cool and other than
that I mean I guess the big news from my
trip to the UK other than the news
that's gonna come at the end of the
podcast in the form of the news from AFC
Wimbledon is that on my sixth day in
England after having spent more than a
hundred dollars on data I did catch mr.
mime I don't know what mr. mime is oh
that's a Pokemon is that a Pokemon yeah
there's the it's the Pokemon that you
can only catch in your oh man that is a
terrible thing that they have done to
people visiting Europe because you could
be looking at Europe and instead you're
looking for a special Pokemon but I
guess it's all part of I mean I Hank
when I found that mr. mime on the banks
of the river next to the Tower of London
I it took me twenty ultra balls 20
raspberries I was sweating I was like
shaking and sweating each time he would
pop out thinking god please don't run
away mr. mime please don't run away by
the way I don't know if you've ever seen
a mr. mime Pogo on
they are distressing looking they are
extremely disturbing they're part of the
scary clown movement of 2016 anyway
when I finally caught him I honestly
like like I didn't start crying but I
did feel the welling up that you feel
before you start crying and then I was
like you've you've got to find some
other meaning to your life man well how
are you doing I'm fine I'm fine
I have not I have not played Pokemon
going months I have not played a video
game in months I am just trying to get
all the things done before I become a
dad and which and at that moment I will
stop making do your hanky John's for a
while so yeah III hear that you may have
some special guests coming up I mean
we've got some great guests it's gonna
be super fun during your paternity leave
but we also might end up skipping a
couple weeks just because I also have a
little bit of personal and professional
business to attend to but no it's gonna
be it's we're get you're gonna have an
awesome paternity leave my only concern
is that you won't want to come back to
work uh yeah I also have that concern I
and I am worried about leaving it all
behind and I think that's natural and
normal and I think it'll all be okay
though it will all be okay you're not
gonna want to leave it all behind
babies are too stressful and
overwhelming to spend 24 hours a day
with anyway Hank would you like a short
poem for the day yeah this poem comes
from WH Auden it's one of the short
poems in his poem three short poems was
recommended by a listener a quite liked
it leaning out over the dreadful
precipice one contemptuous tree hmm I
love those trees John I didn't go
whenever I go tubing down the Clark Fork
River that the Blackfoot I sitting in it
it over inflated tire tube with some
beers and some friends I always loved
looking at those trees that are just
like I'm gonna do this oh yeah it
shouldn't be I shouldn't be here it's it
can't be possible but I'm gonna do it
anyway yeah there is nothing like a tree
clinging to a riverbank in my opinion
it just captures everything about human
life yeah I yeah it's it's remarkable
it's something too because because you
also got to know that like that tree is
just like it's only doing it cuz it can
uh-huh and it can so it's doing it
that's how trees work right I would
argue that might be how we work - let's
answer a question from our listeners all
right this one is from Maria who asks
dear Hank and John when a stranger in a
coffee shop asks you to keep an eye on
their stuff while they go to the toilet
what are they really asking of you are
you supposed to chase after a thief and
tackle them to the ground or just yell
at anyone who gets too close are you
supposed to watch the stuff get stolen
and then when they get back from the
bathroom just pointed the empty space
where the stuff was and say somebody
took it I've always asked to do this job
and I am never ready for the
responsibility are there any realistic
expectations of me or do people just ask
in order to give themselves slightly
more peace of mind while they pee
alright I got two responses to this Hank
the first thing is that Maria this
speaks very highly of you as a person
because the I am never asked to watch
people's stuff when I'm in a coffee shop
and I always wonder why why don't they
ask me and I've decided it's because
they don't like the look of me and they
think that they'll be advertising that
their stuff is going to be easily
acquirable for the next couple minutes
or maybe it does have that look John
that like please do not talk to me look
I mean I definitely do try to put that
look on in the coffee shop I'm not gonna
lie about that the other thing that I
would say though is that in my opinion
and Hank I don't know if you're gonna
disagree with me when you agree to watch
someone's stuff while they are peeing
you are agreeing for that time to treat
that stuff as your own yeah yeah that's
pretty much what you are being asked to
do and if somebody comes and looks at it
you look at them and they're like well
I'm going to go thief somewhere else
because that's really like coffee shop
thievery is very based upon like
approaching stuff and then looking to
see if anyone looks at you and if
someone looks at you you
to the side and you're like oh that
Danish I should go get a Danish at the
coffee bar shop place yeah distressingly
large amount about coffee shop thievery
well it's you know I've had stuff stolen
from me in bars and coffee shops and it
occurs to me how that like I've then it
is like how did that happen
oh here's how it happens and you know
you just sort of walk it up to the stuff
as if it's yours and if somebody looks
at you like that's not yours then you
were like oh I
it's not my stuff in fact there was
recently a case in my neighbourhood of
people just walking into people's back
doors and stealing stuff and several
times they walked into people's houses
and well and the people were home and
they said hello and then the people who
walked in and said is this Dean's house
I thought this was Dean's house and
they're like no it's not Dean's house
and then they walked away but they
caught them because all those people saw
their faces and they just kept doing it
suspiciously bad thieving it turns out
the theft is often done by people who
are not particularly good at theft right
so long story short Maria to get back to
your question says is this Dean stuff
you should say no you should treat that
the P and that is your obligation to
that stuff if you agree to be that
person ok can we move on to another
question I'm shocked you didn't ask the
question I'm about to ask as the first
question of the day because it is
clearly the most important all right you
go ahead and tell me your question John
you know which one I'm referring to
don't you know I don't yes you do this
comes from Emmy and she writes dear John
and Hank oh that's of that one I walk in
a package distribution center loading
the trucks that go out for delivery and
we often get these large containers
which are full of bull semen I live in
Montana so this is not weird
I mean I love Montana too and me and I
have never seen a large canister of bull
semen but continue I live in Montana so
this is not weird
I mean receiving a large canister of
bull semen is never not weird I don't
care if you work in a bull semen
processing Factory it's still weird
anyway yesterday one of these canisters
had been in Korea
please sealed Oh God and was not placed
on the conveyor belt very cottagey
double Oh God as a result that the
canister fell off the belt burst open
and when it hit the floor I was doused
in bull see this this was unfortunate I
mean that's a really good use of
understatement there are things that are
unfortunate and then there's getting
doused with bull semen at work which I
believe is the kind of thing that you
can like I believe you could file a
lawsuit anyway use the emergency shower
at the facility yeah I took another
shower when I got home since then I have
taken two more showers and despite
knowing that I really have nothing to
worry about at this point I still don't
feel clean I'm debating just sort of
covering myself in Purell or maybe
taking a Purell bath do you think of
Purell baths is a good idea and if not
what would you suggest instead and she
signed it in haste writing a really
wonderful email Emmy has permanently
solved the question of how you end your
emails always in them in haste oh my
goodness I have so many questions I so I
know a little bit about about semen and
I know that it is not stable and so it
has to be cooled in order to keep it
alive and usually like i IE n any
biological sample you usually put it
into liquid nitrogen and so i'm curious
whether m ii was in fact dosed in bull
semen like cuz i if it's going out for
transport it's got to be cooled so maybe
i don't know it seems unlikely to me
that there would be of that of just
semen on all on its own but i don't know
the specifics of the situation it seems
like any knows what she's talking about
she obviously had to use the emergency
shower the facility that it doesn't seem
like it's a made-up story but well i
mean it's i don't know what you have
made it I don't have any advice for what
- I mean I think the right thing to do
is it the contaminate
that you feel Emmy is not a biological
contamination right like you're right
you're fine but you did have what is an
objectively horrible thing happen to you
and it's going to take as long as it
takes to forget about it and but I don't
think that you will be permanently
harmed you're not going to have a human
couch I'll everything is gonna be fine
it's just it's just a very I also do not
want to minimize how incredibly bad this
is it is very bad it is a it is a 10 it
is a 10 bad you it is bad I don't it's a
very bad situation you haven't you're
having a lady Lady Macbeth moment you're
having an out damned spot out I say
damned spot moment and the and the Spy
is not blood in this case and it's not
cloth it's yourself and it's bull see
that's might be my favorite Shakespeare
reference you've ever made Hank also the
only Shakespeare reference you've ever
made very very likely I had to google it
Oh God
that's why you were so suspiciously
quiet that what it I mean let let's just
pause I wonder if there's something I
mean I just ah man really I can't even
finish a sentence right now Hank it's so
setting to me to even consider but I I
wanted to read that email primarily
because of the parenthetical aside I
live in Montana so this is not weird
because now every time I come and I see
you Hank I'm gonna be like you guys got
bull semen in the fridge what's going on
yeah where's uh yeah I feel like a yeah
I mean obviously the dftba warehouse
handles bull semen it's a warehouse in
Montana so we do we do the shirts we do
the posters and then we have the bull
semen area well yeah I mean obviously
it's gotta be it's your number one
Internet source for rhett and Link mugs
busy waiter t-shirts and of course you
know freeze-dried bull semen yeah it's
uh you know it's branded it's it's dftba
and bull semen yeah and you can get it
now dftba.com it comes from my
understanding is that it you know it
comes from a very specific kind of
awesome cow yes it comes from a very
Ocelot how that did not forget to be
awesome it's called a a HOF some Steiner
boo-boo I no longer one a pod with you
[Laughter]
tried so hard let's move on okay I
apologize I apologize
this one's from V it's a more serious
question its we talked about this a
little bit before we even began the pod
before we started recording dear Hank
and John I'm a Hillary supporter but my
boyfriend really dislikes her to the
point of supporting Trump now normally
ideals that line up with Trump's would
be a deal-breaker for me but his
reasoning is that Trump doesn't care
about the things that he's saying and
won't actually implement any of the
policies that he says he will I don't
want to break up this five-year
relationship for something so stupid
especially since he's wonderful and
caring and thoughtful
it's our first election year and I've
seen people on Facebook just unfriending
people because they disagree with them
how do i navigate political
disagreements while maintaining our
relationship I don't know you were the
one highlighted this question go I take
it back I don't know how to address this
question it's just so hard I mean I I
just I think I I feel very lucky then I
want to wake up on the morning of
November 10th man yeah yeah I hope
hopefully it will all be decided then I
just I have flashbacks to mm all the
time but yeah I feel very lucky that I
share a house and a life with someone
who I agree with on most political
things not all certainly but I don't
know how I would handle that and
especially this year when it seems to be
deeper than deeper than policy much
deeper than policy and
terms of the the way that it's been
discussed it and and the well yeah there
aren't even any policy discussions at
all at this point yeah I mean we're
hearing almost nothing about policy or
different ideas about how to run the
country instead you know we're hearing
that the other is a demon or has hatred
in their heart or whatever and and it's
really difficult in that kind of
political climate to you know love
someone who disagrees with you about
this stuff that feels fundamental to who
you are and I don't have a great
solution to that I wish that we could
talk about policy in a way that was
civil yeah but I also understand why why
lots of people find that difficult you
know asking somebody to have a civil
conversation with someone who says I
don't believe that you should have
certain rights is difficult like it's
very difficult very difficult thing yeah
it's uh it it when you're when when
you're ideology is an attack it is very
difficult not to begin the conversation
feeling attacked and and I think that a
lot of people feel that on both sides
whether that's you know whether that's
real or not I think that that it's
almost preferred by the people who are
trying to get people out to vote that
you do feel that way and oh yeah I know
that motivates but yeah and sometimes
it's sometimes it is manufactured and
it's hard to tell the difference between
those things and sometimes it's only
partially manufactured but but it's I
don't know I do I read a recent study
that you know of all the differences
people have between each other parents
of children say that they of all like
religion race other ideological stuff
like the the thing that they don't want
is for their child to marry someone of a
different political party and that's
like wow okay man yeah and like and when
I think about it I'm like yeah okay I
can see how that's the case
and that's that's really tough it's
tough tough tough yeah I think it's
really hard I think you just have to try
to find ways to have open conversations
of people are in marriages where this is
a disagreement
and and so just because Hank and I don't
do it doesn't mean it's not possible it
just seems it just seems difficult to us
I also did recently see a study that 45%
of trump support of of men who support
Trump think that their wives are voting
for Trump and 33% of them actually are
so there is a certain number of people
who just don't know and don't discuss it
and I think that that is is troubling
and I think that the main I don't know I
think that's fine people I'm not yet
judged by somebody I married I agree but
I think the main thing is that you guys
understand your values and and that
those values are compatible with each
other and and if you and if this is like
a caring loving person then like you
know we all want the best thing you know
if you guys want this like similar
things and you want the best thing for
each other then you know I don't know
it's so hard to even say the words that
we're gonna come after that sentence but
they're they're implied John do you want
to ask a question I was a great that was
just a great bit of oratory Hank I
wonder if I could have the two hundred
most recent words you said tattooed onto
my body for the rest of my life if you
just if you you know I don't know thank
you
I want to have that tattooed on my body
yeah that that well I've heard
presidential candidates say things that
made less sense not very recently not
since Roe have I've been so moved by
speech okay I will answer Kaitlyn's
question this question comes from
Caitlin who writes Dear John and Hank
I'm hoping you can solve a pervasive
etiquette issue I'm a
young able-bodied person and also a
germaphobe and have always flushed
public toilets with my feet no matter
how high are difficult to reach the
flush button or handle I do not put my
bare hand on it I was taught to do this
as a kid and never thought about it
until I broke my ankle and couldn't lift
my foot to flush it dawned on me then
that millions of people aren't able to
balance or lift a foot and have to put
their hands not only on a toilet flush
er but on one that other people like me
are constantly rubbing bathroom floor
germs on from their feet so what is the
proper etiquette here Caitlin I had a
friend when I was in college who was in
a wheelchair for whole her whole life
she's still in a wheelchair and I one
day was it a crosswalk and they have
those little cross walkie buttons that
you push to make the to make the the
light turn and I in my gymnastic self
jumped up kicked that button and did a
little spinny just to have some fun and
she looked at me and was like don't do
that and I was like why and she was like
I have to touch that with my hand and
now you footed it you did the foot thing
to it ever since then out and like of
course I was like oh my god I'm on the
worst but of course it's not something
that we're always thinking about and
that's fine but I will say bundle up a
piece of toilet paper and push down on
the on the thingy and then throw the
toilet paper in the in the toilet and
you don't have to touch it with your
foot or your hand another thing that I
do is I just don't use my fingertips
because it's really the fingertips that
are the problem just try not to everyone
there touch never put your fingertips on
any surfaces because you're not gonna be
able to stop your fingertips from
touching your face so just make sure
your fingertips only touch your palms
that's what I try to do when I'm in
public spaces that seems normal
okay John we've got another question
here I think that that's the appropriate
thing
it's from Riley who asks dear Hank and
John how old is too old to go
trick-or-treating I'm a junior in high
school and I am too old to go
trick-or-treating and I feel like that's
my be told but I that's too old
but I don't feel too old to be
trick-or-treating also last year I went
in some of the houses gave out
full-sized candy Bart's two older kids
out there so I feel like this has been
encouraged a little any dubious advice
is greatly appreciated where do you live
that they're giving out full-size candy
bars to encourage people to
trick-or-treat older oh my goodness
I seriously Riley's life in the big rock
candy mountain sounds awesome however
Riley I mean I've got good news and bad
news
the good news is that you have not gone
trick-or-treating for the last time in
your wife the bad news is that you have
gone trick-or-treating for the last time
in your life until you have children and
it will be a different kind of joy that
you will experience then I imagine I
like I can imagine no it's the same joy
you can steal half their candy they
don't even notice especially when
they're like two I mean they start to
notice when they're like Henry would
probably notice now but I could steal
half of it is a great way she'd be none
the wiser when is too young to go
trick-or-treating cuz I'm gonna have a
child on October 23rd can I like walk
around like dressed up my little nugget
as like a chicken nugget and go to be
like no retreat and then take a bunch of
candy for myself is it time am I am I
ready to ice tree that's actually one of
the things they're gonna tell you at the
hospital Hank is that you should not be
parading your eight-day love child
around outside in the freezing Montana
cold introducing that child to strangers
fine food candy John I'll give the kid a
little bit of the candy but I'll take
most well you first off you cannot give
an 8 day old child can I feel like maybe
I didn't read the baby books that I said
the Snickers bars I'll match them up
real good make some vixen with some
mother's milk in a blender I don't mean
oh no no no no it's like you don't even
have an awareness of how they how they
eat
but anyway it's all gonna be fine
but let's get back let's get back to
Riley uh Riley I I think that I think
it's time to say goodbye to
trick-or-treating and I know I know it's
hard I actually remember feeling really
sad but I think if you quit now
it will feel better you know what you
can do instead is you can give out the
candy at your house and the other thing
that's so cute yeah it's so much yeah
well you get to see all these little
kids and they come to your house and one
of them's dressed us in Napoleon and
you're like oh that's so cute you're
Napoleon and then he's like i'm louis
xiv and then you're like don't be
pedantic it's fun like why are you being
a jerk about the fact that you're Bowie
the 14th instead of Napoleon like I'm
not a French historian eight-year-old
child and also like what's wrong what
you're being terribly parented that you
would even think to make that correction
to somebody who's giving you candy I'm
sorry I've I've lost the I've lost the
thread of the conversation i mean louis
xiv doesn't look anything like Napoleon
okay so it could not so disappointed you
for making that mistake to that poor
child who was obviously had a great
Louie xiv thank no no that's that's
exactly where you're wrong the kids
Louie the fourteenth costume was
terrible obviously if you've got a high
quality louie xiv costume I'm gonna know
it's Louie 214 this kid he was wearing
what was essentially like a French
military uniform from what I was
guessing was the 19th or 18th centuries
so like I don't remember seeing kingly
xiv dressed I remember him seeing him
dressed up in like Royal garb not
looking like he's in the military
who's the obvious French military person
chimera obviously its Napoleon Bonaparte
so anyway I'm still a little mad about
it as you can tell yeah the problem is I
thought that you had made up a story and
you had no no I do not like being
corrected by strangers you can tell
ongoing theme of Dear John and Hank yeah
Riley you need to be handing out the
candy rather than walking around and
getting it but I will tell you an
amazing secret we
is that when you become the person who
buys the trick-or-treat candy rather
than the person who goes around
scrounging from house to house trying to
score the occasional full-size Snickers
bar when you become the person who buys
the candy you can intentionally over buy
candy oh I mean you you can also
accidentally over buy candy which is the
only thing I've ever done as a person
who gives away candy I mean I always
have I would argue that don't get way
more candy by being the candy purchaser
than by being a trick-or-treater
you also get the exact candy you want
exactly that's right you don't have to
be you don't have to like rummage
through all the all the skittles and the
Smarties to try to find that one Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup or I guess I should
stay on brand that one minute Snickers
you can just choose to get 100% mini
Snickers yeah yeah oh man I get the I
get them I get the Mars pack that's the
Snickers the Three Musketeers and and
the Milky Way's cuz I love the variety
but like I love you know if it's just me
on a regular day I want a Snickers but
if but if I'm gonna have a bunch then I
want I want to mix it up yeah
well I I will say that I agree with you
Hank that Mars is the best candy company
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's also the second-best planet oh I
mean I guess I don't know doesn't
doesn't like Alpha Centauri have a
planet in the habitable zone I might be
for that one first one last thing I want
to say about Halloween Hank mmm-hmm
there's this Golden Age that I think
Riley is just entering where you don't
have to wear a Halloween costume and
then like you get to college and you
start having to wear Halloween costumes
to go to Halloween parties and then when
you're in your 20s you have to go to
Halloween parties and then all of a
sudden you have to start wearing
Halloween costumes because you have kids
and they expect you to dress up like
Henry wants to dress up as a Pikachu he
wants me to dress up as a pokemon
trainer and like I don't want to do that
but I also don't want to be a terrible
father so I
would say Riley enjoy these few years of
not having to dress up because you're
gonna have like basically you're gonna
go straight from the Halloween party
scene probably to the Halloween
parenting scene and then you're gonna
have to wear a costume essentially every
Halloween until you're like sixteen
mm-hmm yeah I had not occurred to me
this avatar costume as an adult parent
person I assume that that stops at like
10 or 12 when it stops being like a
couple's thing I cap a father-son thing
you just yeah they go out on their own
with dressed however that I don't know
maybe maybe maybe maybe by the time I'm
45 years old
I won't have to wear a Halloween costume
every Halloween but I'm just saying if I
were Riley right now I would be grateful
for the break well that brings us to our
sponsorship John which comes from the
pokémon trainer costume of choice
available now at that terrible pop-up
store in your town where they sell
things that are that are the worst
quality of anything you've ever
experienced for slightly more than
they're worth and of course today's
podcast is also brought to you by dftba
bull semen
dftba bull semen your number one source
online for ice-cold bull semen available
now at dftba.com those podcasters of
course also brought to you by Purell
which will come in handy when the
cannister of bull semen arrives at your
house structurally not intact
we apologize please contact dftba help
desk if you ever have problems with your
bull semen we do we do apologize in
advance for the fact that 100% of the
bull semen canisters we send out have
been improperly sealed
and lastly today's podcast is brought to
you by louie xiv louis xiv
just to be clear he was not a general
yeah he was gotta have all the all the
animal furs and the Velvets that's what
you're looking for for louis xiv child
pedantic child and never comes it never
come to John's house again do you want
to do another cool
seriously I do not want to see you this
year I will recognize you forever and
I'll be like hey what's up Napoleon
that's from now on okay hey let's answer
a few more questions from our listeners
do you want to do it's more serious one
or a more sciency one John I wanted well
it's my turn to ask a question for the
record Oh fine fine you go then this
question comes from Claire who asks Dear
John and Hank I'm in the process of
getting over a breakup and I'm having
trouble whenever I hear songs that we
bonded over I think of him and it
saddens me I still enjoy these songs and
don't want to remove them from my life
one cannot simply remove Hamilton from
life but how do I reclaim them to make
them my own instead of ours oh man I
don't know because I because I still
can't listen to rush I mean how do you
go on actually I can't listen to rush I
did not go out with that girl for very
long but she loved rush and I listened
to a lot of rush for those couple months
and purely because of her interest in
Rush and now I realized that I don't
like rush so that worked out really well
for me actually
yeah but rush is not Hamilton Hank like
this is Hamilton that we're talking
about Hamilton has been taken away from
Claire the greatest musical of our time
and possibly any time is suddenly not
available to her and that is a real
bummer yeah this actually happened to me
with a clash album that I listened to a
lot not while with a person but during a
breakup and I don't know why but I just
listened to this clash album like over
and over and I loved the classroom when
every one of those songs comes on the
radio I think about those bad times and
yeah even with all of the exposure I
have had because it's not like these
songs don't painter end in my life it
still happens so I don't have a good
answer for you yeah I mean I've got bad
news for Claire which is that I don't
think there's any ever ever anyway to
totally extricate those songs from their
original context in which you listen to
them like when I listen there's this
band I love they change names over the
years the palace brothers Bonnie Prince
Billy Will Oldham you've listened to
some of their music
you think yeah in fact I know that
you've been listening to their music
because it's been coming up in my
youtube recommended area oh yeah I've
been listening to this YouTube playlist
I created when I'm working on my new
story called adolescence that's not
really songs from my adolescence but
it's songs that make me feel the way the
songs from my adolescence made me feel
because unfortunately the actual songs
from my adolescence do not make me feel
that way oh man that's a good project
for awesome perk right there that the
link to that playlist oh it's a pretty
personal playlist but yeah I I guess I
guess we could do it as a project for
awesome perk anyway I have been
listening to this one song over and over
and over again called we all us three
will ride by will oldham when he was
recording his palace brothers and I had
probably heard that song three hundred
times in the last month and all three
hundred times I have thought about the
same freaking girl so I do not have any
good news for Claire at all I just
wanted to read the question so that I
could tell you that story well it sucks
getting your heart broken sucks breaking
up sucks there's nothing else you can
say about it like it gets it does get
better over time but it sucks it's very
sad yeah oh man I'd hate to have that
happen to Hamilton
I'm so happy to you know a lot of people
are like you know you've been with a
person for a certain amount of time it
gets a little bit boring boy do I love
that I love security and and comfort in
the in the knowledge that I love this
person and she loves me and oh yeah it's
so it's so good it's so good marriage is
the best I mean marriage is just the
best is the most underrated of the major
institutions yeah
yeah and I think that I think that it's
uh it's good to recognize that and feel
good in it you know it's the most
overrated institution dating because
that sounds awful that brings us to our
next question this question comes from
Mikael who
Dear John and Hank I went on a tinder
date recently I just want to pause and
look up into the heavens
and literally thank God that I got
married before the tinder era began
although I will say I have a friend who
shall remain nameless who occasionally
lets me take control of her let's say
and I take control of her tinder and it
is super fun to swipe left and right
super fun anyway um I went on tinder it
recently and when I met him I went in
for a hug
hugs don't normally give me problems but
while I went in for a hug he stuck out
his hand for a handshake which resulted
in my arms being wrapped around him and
his arm poking and probably permanently
damaging my liver two questions one
which is more appropriate for a first
date a handshake or a hug - how do you
extract yourself from this situation
pumpkins and penguins ah so many
pumpkins and facts michaiah
Hank I have to say that I am NOT I don't
really understand how tinder dates work
so I don't know if the hug or the
handshake is the right call on a tinder
date but on a on a in my era of internet
dating back in the literal
in the literal turn of the millennium my
era of internet dating I almost always
went in for the handshake because I
didn't really know this person yet yeah
yeah I feel like if you don't like I
don't usually hug a person the first
time I see them unless there's some good
reason to I well it depends I don't know
how he start a fight you get with
somebody on tinder before you go on your
first date yeah yeah yeah that's true
like if you have like a really good sort
of like texts texting that's happening
then yeah maybe going for the for the
for the hug but in general I think the
first time you meet somebody a handshake
is a good low barrier non intense way of
connecting and I think it'd be weird if
you just waved and sat down I think a
handshake is good oh I told some times I
totally do the wave and sit-down thing
if I'm not yeah I'm not looking to have
my fingertips touch another human being
I'm not afraid to wave pass it down
yeah and it's all fine and I think that
the important thing
is that the so there's sort of like a
sliding scale and you just respect the
person who's on the the side of least
contact you know like just like try and
read them and that's really what this
question for me is about like how like
how do you handle it when you do the
arms wide thing and they do the hand out
thing and you handshake you have to but
it's always gonna be a bit but also like
recognizing like I did the thing cuz
everybody does it it's not like a thing
that has never happened before it's a
constantly occurring thing and I did the
thing and hahahahahaha that was awkward
good way to start this out right now
that's a great way to deal with it Hank
did you ever do any internet dating no I
did a bunch I feel like I should have a
secondary podcast where I discussed my
internet dating stories from the 90s and
early 2000s or really just the earliest
2000 I definitely have like internet
like people I liked on the internet and
we would write like like we we had like
a connection of a sort that that I think
both people felt but they never went
into the real world right right I know I
mean my first my first real relationship
the first time I fell in love was
somebody I met on CompuServe in the
early 90s so I was internet dating
before most of you were born John was
the first Internet date er I don't know
if anyone knows this about him it's on
his Wikipedia page sometimes I think
that sometimes I think that she and I
our relationship might have been like
the first teenage relationship to emerge
from CompuServe but I might be wrong
you were really - yeah - that whole vibe
though and we I have to say like I I
mean I have super complicated mixed
feelings about most of my exes but I
have nothing but positive things to say
about her and she's gone on to have a
wonderful life and is a lovely person
Hank you knew her
yes yeah she was lovely yeah it's great
yeah really lovely like yeah just just a
great great person and we never even saw
picture of each other before we met in
real life it's crazy the world was so
different then pink let's answer another
question I've got one right here
it's from Janet who asks dear Hank and
John I know there's a freshwater
shortage because too much of it's busy
being 75% of 7 billion human bodies so
it can't go in the rivers and stuff I
also know that much of the Earth's water
was delivered to us by comets my
question is why can't we pull some
comets into decaying orbit with earth to
get more water I'm guessing we can't or
something or I'm guessing we can't or
someone would have tried it already I
just want to know why we can't well
Janet I have to say that you have just
proposed crashing a comet into earth
that's a terrible idea Janet that's like
of all the ideas that I've ever heard on
dear Hank and John that might be my
least favorite one decaying orbit with
earth yes yes you've proposed crashing a
comet into earth don't do that it would
be very very difficult to do and also
don't do it people have suggested doing
this to Mars to help increase the amount
of water on Mars and also the amount of
gas in the atmosphere which would kick
off a greenhouse effect but yeah mmm
it's comets are big and it requires a
lot of energy to move them but
definitely a thing that I could see a
future you know future intelligent human
endeavor attempting on a planet that did
not have really robust ecosystems and
billions of people on it well there is
no way that humans will live long enough
to start pulling comets into into
planets there's just no way I'm not even
totally confident about our ability to
make it to 2017 yeah well you know it's
all odds John it's all the odds like I
think that it's way below way below 1%
that we're gonna crash and burn in the
next few years but uh it's I feel like
it's I feel like it's higher than it
than it once was we're a very powerful
species we have a lot of control over
our planet
and and are in the early days of
understanding the level of control that
we have and are not good at respecting
and that yet but I think we're gonna get
there no well I appreciate your optimism
Hank it's time to move on to the news
Mars Wow AFC Wimbledon oh man
I didn't realize how late do you want to
go first or do you want me to go first I
don't mind going first
I'll go first because I think that your
news is pretty big and pretty good mine
was hard there's so much news from Mars
this week John I think that I'm gonna go
with as it's been a marzi week yeah I'm
gonna go with even though this is
probably the one that people have most
heard about I'm gonna go with Barack
Obama's editorial that he published on
CNN saying that the US will send Mars to
the Red Planet well nope that's not make
any sense we'll say that would be we are
people to the Red Planet by the 2030s
and return them safely to earth with a
longer-term goal of making it possible
to quote one day remain there for an
extended time and that's a terrible
that's terrible news as everyone knows
but he committed to some funding for
NASA for this and also said that it
would be a joint effort between public
and private company things people
projects programs I don't know what I
mean what do I mean John it'll be I
don't know what that - don't know father
- it's gonna be a joint effort between
public companies and the government is
what I mean and yeah but the problem
with that is that SpaceX hasn't planned
to get there before 2028 and Obama wants
to be there in 2030s so I'm ready to it
for that guy to leave office and get
somebody else in there is a little bit
more ambitious yeah I for one and with
Leon muss on this news which Leon must
immediately upon hearing about this news
went to Twitter
Leon must for Earth but number four Leon
most number for Earth and he announced
he has how incredibly excited he was and
wanted to underscore how much he's
always liked Barack Obama
who's the kind of leader who can make
sure that humans stay here on earth
where they belong
until at least 20 28 when this podcast
will be renamed Dear John and Hank Hank
the news from AFC Wimbledon is amazing
so as you will recall when we last
recorded a podcast AFC Wimbledon was was
playing the Coventry City like during
the recording of the podcast and I
believe AFC Wimbledon was down one nil
they came back they tied that game 2-2
and since then they have gone on a tear
so the first thing that happened is that
I went to London we weren't there - just
to see AFC Wimbledon but it was a nice
added bonus so we got to go to King's
meadow I was there with Sarah and
rosianna and our friends Stuart and Anne
Murray and their beautiful children and
it was just it was a lovely day out made
even more lovely by the fact that AFC
Wimbledon won that game to nil it was
incredibly exciting fun to watch great
play it was really it was it made me
feel like AFC Wimbledon are gonna be
fine potentially in Ligue 1 because they
really played well then they played in
the Football League trophy they played
Plymouth Argyle who you'll recall is the
team we played at Wembley to get to
Ligue 1 in the first place won that game
2-1 also you know who started in that
game Hank no my very favorite new AFC
Wimbledon player the teenage ginger
Messi his name is Alfie Egan and he is
gonna be a fantastic player then they
played Oxford that game was actually
televised in the UK so I was able to
watch it by a totally legal stream and
they won that game 3-1 whoa so AFC
Wimbledon have gone from being near the
bottom of the table in a situation where
like they were pretty much you know
staring the possibility of relegation in
the face to being 10th place in Ligue 1
on 16 points after 12 games and they are
one point above guess who the franchise
currently playing
Milton Keynes Hank AFC Wimbledon which
formed in 2002 which had public tryouts
on Wimbledon common which started out in
the ninth tier of English football for a
little bit of context Hank let's go back
to 2004 twelve years ago oh gosh I do
should we do that
should we definitely do that you've
talked for a long time and people know
the story all right all right there a
little bit of context Hank if we just go
back to 2004 AFC Wimbledon are playing
in the 8th tier of English football at a
stadium that seats 2,200 people the
franchise currently playing in Milton
Keynes are a middling two crap team in
the third tier of English football
league one playing in a mostly empty
stadium that seats 15,000 people
flash forward 12 years AFC Wimbledon
have been promoted five times they are
still playing in a stadium that seats
2,200 people but they are above Milton
Keynes on in the table Milton Keynes
still being a middling to crap team in
the third tier of English football it is
an amazing story this is the first time
since reforming that AFC Wimbledon have
been above Milton Keynes in the table
the teams playing great I'm sorry I talk
so long but I'm very very excited you
can get your dftba nerdfighteria AFC
wimbledon scarves now at dftba.com and
while you're there you can get yourself
some bull semen as well you're only four
points out of the top of the table John
out of out of like promotion four points
from from being in a promotion spot four
points from being in the playoffs yes I
made look I've learned at this point not
to say that something isn't going to
happen but AFC Wimbledon I will remind
you used to have the smallest stadium in
the league - now they have the smallest
statement it is very hard to imagine the
mapping the smallest stadium in the
championship but whatever at this point
I'm just loving the ride all right well
I'm excited for you John do you want to
tell us a little bit about what we
learned today huh we learned that you
can catch a mr. mime if you are focused
willing to you
a lot of money for international data
and have a lot of ultra balls we learned
that John may have had the very first
teenage dating relationship that came
out of the internet platform CompuServe
that's right I have the first and
arguably best CompuServe love story we
learned that after you break up with
somebody you can never listen to those
songs again in quite the same way but
eventually you will be able to listen to
them but you will always still think of
that person I'm sorry it's terrible news
but that has been my experience and we
learned that crashing comets into planet
Earth is not a good way to increase the
amount of freshwater that we have well
could we crush a very small comet onto
planet Earth
uh no I mean you maybe you could no no
no it would I mean it wouldn't be
helpful for one thing we have lots of
water and we have lots of frozen water
it's not like we don't have big hunks of
frozen water that's you know wonderful
fresh water that is already on the
planet and if we've burned a comment up
in the atmosphere like the goal would be
that it would not strike the surface of
the earth you'd still be just getting
that into the atmosphere which would
then rain down all over the planet and
mostly land in the oceans anyway all
right I trust you you seem to know what
you're talking about Hank thanks for
podding with me it's always a pleasure
thanks to all of our listeners
especially those who support us on
patreon at patreon.com slash dear Hank
and John you can subscribe now for a
dollar or more per month and you get
access to a free live show not free I
don't know why I said free it's
definitely not free it's a dollar a
monthly live show which is like this
only with our faces so kind of by some
measures worse and I also want to thank
rosianna halse rojas who helps out with
questions Nicholas Jenkins who edits
this podcast our theme music is from
gunnarolla Victoria buongiorno she does
all of the social media and uploads
these things so thank you for thank you
to her for that you can email
your questions at Hank and John at
gmail.com you can also reach us on
Twitter using the hashtag dear Hank and
John I'm Hank green John is John Green
and as they say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Applause]
[Music]